Now why is this called the probability density function? Well, let's say we're
taking a random sample of Udacity students. Here's a histogram representing
Udacity students' ages, and the sample size is 7,901. This is actual data. Let's
model it with this probability density function. Now remember when we model it,
the absolute frequency turns into relative frequency, and here I've put
probability and you'll see why. We know from our sample that about 70% of
Udacity students are aged 30 or less. Now, let's say we randomly choose any
Udacity student by giving each one of you, and all other Udacity students, a
unique number. And then we randomly pick a number. Then what's the probability
that the person that we choose will be age 30 or less. Write your answer as a
proportion.